nearby and for example we have been able to move
more than 1,374 tons of
what is being removed from the site,
we are obviously still focused on the
coffee search operation and that
is why we are offering engineers and
experts regarding what the building is  that
it has not been connected that is the
biggest concern that we have
now we are going to continue coordinating to
ensure that what the operation is
in search of rescue they can
resume and we are giving options with
our experts to coordinate with the
chief and we are going to  stay on that course
so thank you for being here
on the road 5
o
yes waiting
on the live version 15 on the team
but on the report
ok
lifting itself is with johnny it was on
paper with 76
we are here to  quickly share
information about operations as
many of you have already seen we had
to stop operations in the
early hours of the morning due to
structural concerns about the
building that is still standing we are
doing everything possible to protect
the safety of our terrorists and
continue with the search and
rescue operation the engineers are monitoring and
showing the building to assess the
situation and the next steps also
with the help of the state
I want a tie  to emphasize that the visit
of the president and byron
has nothing to do with any impact on
our search and
rescue operation the only reason for the pause
is concerns about the building and
we will move forward as soon
as we can we have already informed the families
until  tomorrow and answered all your
questions we will continue to keep
the families and the press informed
as we get new information
on the situation and when the pp as
bag of the seven when we have more
information the boss with minsk and now he is going
to give more detailed information on  the
situation
the first month madrid although month
die
of this opera grace jones day  sunshine
export was primed with 6 stocks or engineers
people
[Music]
at the show
in one
that
i
miriam from projection erika venitas
very good morning based on the
recommendations of the engineers
we had to temporarily suspend
operations to reevaluate our
options on how we can continue  these
operations safely today at
2:11 a.m. operations were
temporarily suspended due to
building stability concerns the suspension of these
operations was based on various
recommendations from
structural engineers the concern is
evaluated include 6 to 12 inches  of
movement in a large column
hanging from the structure that could
fall causing damage to support columns
in the underground area of the garage plus
light movement in the concr
te floor at the rear of the build
ng that could cause additional failure of th
s structure  movements
on the debris adjacent to the
back of the structure
we will also continue to evaluate and
monitor these data points
our incident team works with
structural engineers and
subject matter experts to develop
options to continue our
operation thank you very much
[Music]
and that
ah
yes
yes to mustard until the operation stopped
as they recovered family members
and human remains to touch the
recovered model nothing because we are
unemployed but the fastest it opens
in the operation
[Music]
like him
not since the two  last numbers that
we told you were 18 we have not
found a victim grace
in greek
regarding the culture we have
abroad and cristian to the figures
oberá
uy
d
[Music]
in him
efe
in sex
before the beginning of the search if
we hear sounds  of a voice apparently
that was a woman after
searching and trying to get to the place
where this person was
after u  n time and the search continued we did not
hear from this person anymore apparently
the person dies
because like all the proximity
and
of
richter really